bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir jusqu'où ira la
récupération du meurtre de la petite
Lola Éric Zemmour participe ce soir à
une manifestation d'hommage à cette
fillette de 12 ans atrocement assassiné
Marine Le Pen avait prévu d'y aller à la
changer d'avis elle a préféré se
recueillir devant l'Assemblée nationale
ce soir revirement politique stratégique
après ce fait divers abonninables nous
en parlerons un drame qui relance aussi
le débat sur l'exécution des
occf les obligations à quitter le
territoire nous en débattrons notre
grand témoin ce soir est un économiste
et un homme de gauche après le succès de
son Traité d'économie hérétique il
revient avec mon dictionnaire d'économie
chez Fayard un guide de vulgarisation
conçu comme un manuel d'autodéfense
contre la pensée dominante thomas
Porcher est avec nous ce soir enfin
trois affranchis trois parties pris ce
soir raisins mandingava quand un 49-3 en
cash un autre le regard de Richard Werly
sur le naufrage de listrus
démissionnaire aujourd'hui après un
passage éclair au thème Downing Street
et puis Vincent le jeu qui va revenir ce
soir sur le retour en France de 40
enfants de djihadiste et de 14 mères de
Siri tournant dans la doctrine française
voilà pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
il y a des jours où la politique devient
indécentes cette journée en est-elle une
on va revenir ce soir sur la manière
dont certains partis politiques se sont
rués sur le meurtre sordide de la petite
Lola et de tenter de poser sereinement
cette question ce crime atroce
relève-t-il de ce que la société aurait
pu éviter bonsoir Benjamin Haddad merci
d'être là vous êtes député renaissance
de Paris porte-parole du groupe
majoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
bonsoir Edwige Dias bienvenue sur ce
plateau député rassemblement national de
Gironde bonsoir maître Corinne
judicielli Yann vous êtes avocate au
barreau de Paris et spécialiste du droit
des étrangers la journaliste au Monde
spécialiste des questions migratoires
Julia Pasqual va nous rejoindre dans un
tout petit instant juste après le billet
de Blacko qui va nous planter le décor
de ce qui se passe en ce moment même du
côté de la place d'enfer Rochereau ainsi
que devant l'Assemblée nationale si j'ai
bien compris Stéphane Lacoste qui tout
de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes à tous
Myriam la Eric Zemmour et Marine Le Pen
ont tous les deux décidés de rendre un
hommage public à la mémoire de Lola mais
chacun de son côté donc il y a Éric
Zemmour qui lui a choisi de se rendre
rassemblement organisé vous voyez les
images place d'enfer Rochereau élu vous
rendrait des comptes sur la banderole
voilà tandis que Marine Le Pen elle a
préféré organiser une minute de silence
donc devant l'Assemblée nationale avec
ses élus et elle dément bien sûr qu'il
s'agit de récupération alors pourtant
les parents de Lola
voilà Marine Le Pen donc
les parents de Lola ont fait savoir
pourtant qu'il ne voulait surtout pas de
récupération sauf que malheureusement
l'émotion soulevée par la finale de leur
enfant a emporté tout le pays c'est
franchement c'est pas évident de vouloir
reprocher ou interdire à la classe
politique de réagir sur un crématros
alors que au même moment ce crime atroce
fait la une de tous les médias par un
journal par un radium ou un télé qui
n'est pas mis ce crime elle a une donc
pourtant ce matin Olivier Véran tu es
assez sévère avec cette idée de de
récupération qu'il voulait dénoncer
Aurore berger sur France Inter a dit que
c'était dégueulasse Olivier Véran
porte-marl le gouvernement préfère les
noms d'oiseaux on l'écoute on a vu
naître dès les premières minutes un
certain nombre pardon pour l'expression
mais de l'exploitation de charognard qui
tentent de faire de la politique assez
basse avec des récupérations via des
hashtags pour inciter à des
manifestations à but politique de ce
drame
qui sont les charognards
au soutien d'Éric Zemmour parce que
c'est eux qui ont enregistré trois noms
de domaine qui incluent le prénom de
Lola et en fait on arrive effectivement
le sentiment qu'après son double échec
législatif présidentielle
Eric Zemmour à l'occasion de la mort de
l'Ola fait son retour dans le débat
public vous savez que son ambition c'est
de gagner la bataille des idées il
voudrait remporter la bataille
culturelle contre la gauche et donc pour
ça il arrive avec un nouveau mot qu'il a
créé le mot franco-side qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ce mot là alors il a expliqué
que c'était inspiré pour créer ce mot du
mot féminicide qui aujourd'hui est
employé dans les médias qui est même
entré dans le dictionnaire Larousse donc
un féminicide c'est quand une femme est
tuée en raison de son appartenance au
sexe féminin et ça révèle une violence
plus plus large que celle du patriarcat
donc voilà sur ce modèle là la
définition du mot Franck aussi par celui
qui l'a inventé en écoute
le Franck aussi c'est un crime commis
contre un français par un étranger parce
que je considère qu'aujourd'hui nous
vivons un moment historique qui est que
le peuple français sur son sol et
occupé par un peuple étranger par une
civilisation étrangère qui est en train
de le remplacer donc là on se dit que
Marine Le Pen doit assez contente
d'avoir récupéré son rival préféré qui
lui permet de évidemment d'un seul coup
passer pour beaucoup plus modéré plus
respectable pourtant Jordan Bardella le
président du Rassemblement national par
intérim avait prévu de participer à ce
même rassemblement avec Eric Zemmour
qui sera été conduite par Jordan
mardellen et dès que la famille a dit
qu'elle ne souhaitait pas que cette
manifestation ait lieu le RMC préfère
organise cette minute de silence qu'on a
vu est-ce que c'est de la récupération
est-ce que c'est au contraire une action
politique bon en tout cas ce matin
Marine Le Pen elle sait pas gênée sur
Europe 1 pour rappeler que Lola n'est
pas la première avoir été assassiné par
un étranger qui aurait dû être expulsé
on l'écoute
je vais pas faire la liste mais les deux
jeunes filles de la gare Saint-Charles
égorgée mais le prêtre de Nantes qui
avait été assassiné par celui qui avait
d'ailleurs incendié quelques temps avant
la cathédrale de Nantes et la liste est
trop longue c'est la rhétorique on
appelle ça prétérition je ne vous dis
pas ce que je suis en train de vous dire
mais c'est sûr que rappeler l'attentat
de la gare Saint-Charles qui a eu en
2017 s'est rappelé l'échec du président
Macron puisque en 2017 les deux jeunes
femmes n'en parle Marine Le Pen ont été
tués par un Tunisien qui aurait dû être
expulsé et pourtant quelques jours après
ce crime qui avait choqué tout le monde
s'est attentat d'ailleurs le président
Macron avait promis que désormais il
serait intraitable sont les expulsions
on l'écoute je souhaite que nous
reconduillions de manière intraitable
celles et ceux qui n'ont pas de titre
cette conversion je le sais prendra des
semaines peut-être quelques mois
un peu optimiste
octobre 2017
ans plus tard le problème reste entier
donc est-ce qu'il y a récupération ou
est-ce qu'il y a un vrai débat politique
sur une faille de la politique du
gouvernement ou même de l'État le débat
est ouvert merci
pour ce billet Stéphane Benjamin adage
comment ça avec vous et cette première
partie d'ailleurs avec les politiques on
parlera de façon apaisée de ces fameuses
OCC qtf dans une deuxième partie ce
crime atroce c'est un électrochoc pour
pour le pays tout entier comment vous
regardez ce qui se passe ce soir du côté
de la place d'enfer-rochereau et se
rassemblement à la mémoire de Lola avec
Eric Zemmour et moi j'ai jamais rechigné
à avoir des débats sur l'immigration sur
cette question des auqtf je crois qu'il
faut que notre majorité sans saisie le
ministre de l'Intérieur a fait des
propositions qu'on va examiner notamment
la loi d'immigration je pense au début
de l'année je pense qu'on a intérêt à
avoir une doctrine de fermeté de
maîtrise de contrôle sur ces sujets nous
sommes attendus par les Français
là-dessus et j'en débattrai bien
volontiers mais
je crois que ce à quoi on est assisté
ces derniers jours en termes de de
récupération politique c'est évidemment
ce qui s'est passé sur ce crime de
l'extrême droite uniquement
sur bien
une volonté d'instrumentaliser l'émotion
immense qu'on ressent tous tous en tant
en tant qu'être humain en tant que
personne qui ont des familles certains
des enfants c'est atroce qui s'est passé
je pense qu'on s'associe tous à la peine
à la douleur à la pudeur des parents de
la famille de cette petite fille donc
voilà on fait de la politique
mais il y a je pense que même dans notre
aire de réseaux sociaux même au moment
où
chacun il va de son buzz de son message
il y a évidemment tes limites évidemment
et elles ont été franchies
coupable de cet indécence gênante selon
vous ou pas oui on l'a entendu un peu
après je pense qu'ils ont peut-être vu
aussi la réaction de colère que
provoquer chez beaucoup encore une fois
donc on peut encore une fois moi je ne
dis absolument pas ça pour évacuer un
débat sereiner dans un deuxième temps
parce que c'est pour ça qu'on voulait
bien séparer les choses ne sont pas
liées donc il y a une douleur quand on
quête humain en tant que citoyen on
partage tous face à cette atrocité et
après en tant que responsable politique
ayant un débat apaisé alors Marine Le
Pen elle devait aller à cette
manifestation de d'en faire Rochereau
elle a fait marche arrière toutes en 24
heures est-ce que c'est parce qu'elle
est allée trop loin au départ je pense
que ce qu'elle a voulu polémiquer dès le
départ et qu'elle le regrette non parce
que Marine Le Pen n'est pas du tout dans
la polémique par contre ce que Marie n'a
voulu faire c'est respecter la volonté
des parents c'est la raison pour
laquelle pas plus tard qu'il y a
quelques minutes nous étions nous les
députés du rassemblement national sur la
place du Palais Bourbon pour rendre un
hommage solonel faire une minute de
silence et adresser toutes nos pensées
émues à la famille de cette petite Lola
parce que ce drame il est il est
national je veux dire Lola ça pourrait
être notre fille notre sœur notre nièce
quelqu'un de notre famille donc
évidemment toute la France a été
ébranlée pour autant moi je m'indigne
des accusations de récupération
politique parce que bon marine le
penchantée avec Éric Zemmour qui l'a
rendu infréquentable pour vous moi ce
que je vais vous dire surtout c'est que
c'est que Marine elle a le courage de
dire les choses mardi au moment des
questions au Gouvernement elle a
interpellé madame borne et lui
regrettait pas cette question là mais à
peine quatre jours après il faut bien
poser la question parce que le problème
c'est que tant que le gouvernement
refuse de voir la réalité en face ne met
pas les moyens nécessaires pour faire
appliquer les obligations de quitter le
territoire français et bien on continue
de pleurer des Français et pardon de le
dire mais depuis qu'Emmanuel des sens a
été respecté ce délai ce délai non
récupération politique que réclame la
famille et respectée par le
rassemblement national surtout en fait
ce qui je pense
le plus grand bien à la famille sans
parler à leur place mais en tout cas ce
qui ferait le plus grand bien à la
France c'est que des Français la famille
ou la France les deux parce que je veux
dire cette petite fille je l'ai dit
voilà c'est elle fait partie de notre
famille quelque part voilà et donc le
problème c'est que aujourd'hui rien
n'est fait pour empêcher des personnes
qui sont sous oculaires de quitter le
territoire français on va y venir mais
simplement ce que je voudrais bien dire
c'est que le tour le moment
nous révèle dans l'enquête le problème
c'est pas fini mais je vous laisse finir
mais on va y venir après parce que je
voulais vous faire réagir sur le mot de
Franck aussi qui n'est pas voilà anodin
pour le moins un mot inventé forgé par
Éric Zemmour est-ce qu'il vous choque
est-ce que vous le condamnez
moi je suis consterné par ce que fait
Éric Zemmour il essaie de revenir j'ai
même pas envie de commenter parce qu'en
fait il voit bien qu'il essaie de
revenir dans le jeu politique dans le
jeu médiatique après une campagne qui a
été un échec on a vu à quel point
c'était déconnecté en fait d'installer
dans les esprits c'est que cette petite
fille a été tuée parce qu'elle était
française alors tout ce qu'on sait de
l'enquête pour l'instant c'est que on a
quelque chose d'atroce on va pas revenir
dans les détails de ce qu'on connaît des
circonstances mais on est plutôt dans la
noirceur de l'humain de la psychiatrie
voir de la barbarie que un crime contre
une petite fillette aux yeux bleus après
les premiers éléments de l'enquête Éric
Zemmour c'est un grand partisan de
l'approche gramschiste il faut gagner la
bataille intellectuelle et culturelle
avant de gagner la bataille politique
donc à partir du moment on commence déjà
à commenter et à se cliver sur les
termes qu'il essaie d'imposer dans le
débat c'est déjà une forme de victoire
il vous choque est-ce que vous le
condamnez l'emploi de ce mot ou pas non
mais je laisse Éric Zemmour assez
responsabilité il emploie le terme qui
veut je vais vous dire
on a décidé de porter cette question au
Parlement voilà et donc nous allons agir
il y a la loi sur l'immigration qui
arrive début 2023 nous allons être force
de proposition d'une part nous allons
pointer du doigt ce qui ne fonctionne
pas les l'inapplication des occuts le
manque de moyens pour les organismes
qui est un vieux dossier qui ressurgit à
la faveur de cette de ce dramatros mais
pour vous avec ce que vous connaissez
parce que tout est sur la table c'est
débat on peut les avoir tout le monde
les a sur l'enquête on ne peut pas
considérer que la société
aurait pu éviter
un passage à la psychiatrique c'est ce
qui d'après ce qu'on a des éléments de
l'enquête voilà dans ta pensée est-ce
que est-ce que vous pensez que
il y a une part comme on dit de barbarie
de toutes les sociétés il peut rien à
limite il faut soigner
site Internet ou au contraire c'est
quelque chose que la société aurait pu
éviter oui c'est quelque chose qui
aurait pu être évité parce que si cette
jeune fille avait été renvoyée dans son
pays elle n'aurait pas assassiné Lola
bien je crois qu'on voulait réagir à ça
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça on est
dans la définition de la récupération
pourquoi parce que on est dans un cas où
c'est une femme qui a vu son sa carte de
séjour sans titre de séjour qui n'a pas
été renouvelé à la fin de l'été donc
très récemment qui ne s'était pas rendu
coupable en tout cas pas qu'on sache de
délinquance de crimes dans le passé qui
avait même été apparemment victime
elle-même de violences conjugales ce qui
fait que dans les pays européens dans la
France en France on a tendance au
contraire à protéger à ne pas expulser
ce type de personne comme vous l'avez
indiqué on est dans un cadre
probablement de de
névrose psychiatrique donc je pense que
encore une fois ayons un débat sur
l'intégration sur les îles sur le QT
alors je vous interromps on est à la
chaîne parlementaire et on vérifie ce
qui se passe dans l'hémis cycle
Elisabeth borde vient de déclencher va
déclencher selon toutes vraisemblances
un nouveau 49-3 cette fois sur le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale la dame la présidence de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur général madame et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les députés
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale est un texte
déterminant
il est au fondement de notre modèle
social qui fait la fierté de notre pays
il assure le financement de notre
sécurité sociale qui protège nos
concitoyens particulièrement les plus
fragiles
ce projet de loi porte des politiques
majeures qui touchent directement le
quotidien des Français
et je suis convaincu que nous pouvons
trouver des points d'accord sur bon
nombre d'entre elles
les débats en commission des affaires
sociales nous l'ont montré
je tiens à saluer la qualité des
échanges et des travaux qui s'y sont
tenus sous l'égide de la présidente de
la commission et de la rapporteur
général
[Applaudissements]
ces débats je parle des débats en
commission ont été pour la plupart très
constructifs ils ont permis d'enrichir
le texte avec l'adoption d'amendements
de la majorité comme des oppositions
plusieurs sujets ont d'ailleurs été
portés bien au-delà des clivages entre
les groupes
et ces débats ont abouti à l'adoption de
l'intégralité du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
commission
[Applaudissements]
cependant aujourd'hui à rebours de la
commission vous avez rejeté la première
partie du texte
[Applaudissements]
surtout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
surtout
vous avez dénaturé la deuxième partie
[Applaudissements]
en créant des recettes fictives vous
rendiez le texte insère et donc
inconstitutionnel
[Applaudissements]
en adoptant un amendement qui privait la
médecine de ville de plus d'un milliard
d'euros
au demeurant indispensable
au profit d'autres dépenses vous avez
inéluctablement conduit au rejet d'une
deuxième partie privée de cohérence
alors que les discussions sur la
troisième partie du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
commence
nous ne pouvons pas prendre le risque
d'un nouveau rejet ou d'un texte de
nouveau des naturels
nous avons besoin de cette troisième
partie du PLFSS
sans elle nous ne pourrions garantir les
ressources de la sécurité sociale
sans elle nous ne pourrions poursuivre
le débat sur la partie 4 du texte qui
porte des réformes majeures en matière
de prévention de santé de politique
familiales ou de l'autonomie
[Applaudissements]
aussi sur le fondement de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la troisième partie du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le nouveau texte que je vous soumets
n'est évidemment pas
identique au projet de loi initial du
gouvernement
il a été modifié enrichi améliorer en
tenant compte des débats en commission
[Applaudissements]
il a évolué sur des sujets importants
que vous avez porté notamment la
prolongation des exonérations patronales
pour l'emploi des travailleurs
occasionnels agricoles ou le cumul
emploi retraite des médecins
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
décision que nous prenons ne met pas un
terme au débat parlementaire
au contraire elle va permettre d'ouvrir
la discussion sur la quatrième partie du
texte c'est à dire sur le soutien à
l'autonomie des personnes âgées sur les
aides à la garde d'enfants sur la
prévention sur l'accès aux soins ou
encore sur la lutte contre la fraude je
souhaite et j'espère que nous pourrons
avoir sur ces sujets un débat
constructif et de bonne foi nous sommes
toujours prêts à bâtir prêt à trouver
des compromis et plus que jamais résolu
agir au service des Français je vous
remercie je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
l'Assemblée nationale prend acte de
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement conformément au disposition
de l'article 49 à l'ina3 de la
Constitution le texte sur lequel la
première ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa premier du
règlement le débat sur ce texte est
immédiatement suspendu ce texte sera
considéré comme adopté sauf si une
motion de censure déposée avant demain
19h53 et voter dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse voilà donc
un deuxième 49-3 des déclenché beaucoup
plus vite que le premier si j'ose dire
sur le budget de la Sécurité sociale
votre réaction et le vidjazz mais si une
fois de plus de
sectarisme du mépris et de la mauvaise
foi je rappelle que 66% des Français ne
sont pas favorables à l'utilisation d'un
49-3 et là le gouvernement nous en offre
deux en deux jours je trouve ça purement
révoltant et ensuite je voudrais dire
que Madame born a indiqué que les
articles de la première partie du PLFSS
n'avait pas été adopte les mais moi je
veux juste dire quelque chose pourquoi
ils n'ont pas été adopté parce que la
macronie a déserté l'hémicycle cet
après-midi cet après-midi au moment de
l'article 1er il y avait seulement 66
députés de la majorité qui était là ça
veut dire qu'avec votre groupe
majoritaire il y avait 74% des députés
des majorités
boycoté ils ont saboté ces débats pour
donner pour offrir sur un plateau des
arguments d'une mauvaise foi inouï à
Madame borne Benjamin la première liste
prend ses responsabilités nous depuis le
mois de juin nous sommes dans une
logique très claire on veut faire des
compromis on veut trouver des majorités
sur des textes on a réussi à le faire
sur le pouvoir d'achat on a réussi à le
faire sur la sur un chômage récemment là
que ce soit sur le budget ou le PLFSS le
budget de la sécurité sociale toutes les
oppositions LR e RN la nups nous ont dit
avant même le dépôt du texte qu'il
voterait contre dans le cas du deuxième
49.3 celui qu'on vient de voir il arrive
d'entrée de jeu il arrive d'entrer Dieu
alors pas exactement alors il y a eu un
débat effectivement en commission un
débat qui a été beaucoup plus
constructif que celui qu'on a vu en
hémicycle où là c'était l'explosion de
la dépense publique tout le monde y
aller de son amendement et de milliards
de dépenses puisque on était en
l'irresponsabilité totale donc la France
a besoin de budget on a des amendements
de compromis
issus de la Commission comme le cumul
emploi retrait des médecins d'autres
sujets de ce type dont on vient de
parler la première ministre un moment il
faut avancer et il faut mettre fin
effectivement à ce qui est quand même
une mise en scène théâtrale de la part
des oppositions on vous mettra de toute
façon pas d'accord sur ce sujet on va
reprendre le cours de notre débat avec
nos invités et on va passer à la
question des auqtf obligations de
quitter le territoire français le débat
est relancé à la faveur de ce de ce
crime atroce car la principale suspecte
faisait l'objet de l'une de ces de ces
occult pourquoi ça ne marche pas ou pas
très bien en France on voit cela chiffre
à l'appui avec Elsa monte
qtf quatre lettres pour un des
dispositifs de la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale au qtf pour
obligation de quitter le territoire
français elle peut être notifiée par un
préfet à tout étranger en situation
irrégulière soit après un contrôle
d'identité soit après un refus de
demande d'asile ou de délivrance de
titre de séjour alors l'individu à 30
jours pour quitter le territoire par ses
propres moyens à l'issue de ce délai il
pourra être placé en centre de rétention
administrative ou assigna résidence
c'est l'administration française qui
s'occupera alors de son départ en 2021
62000 au qtf ont été prononcés mais leur
exécution est très faible 5% en 2021 une
faible proportion notamment due à la
crise sanitaire sinon c'est au tour de
15%. pourtant 2019 dans un entretien à
valeur actuelle Emmanuel Macron fix son
objectif de 100% d'exécution alors
pourquoi si peu d'occuper F sont-elles
menées à leur terme tout d'abord il y a
la possibilité de faire un recours
ensuite les autorités n'ont pas toujours
connaissance de la localisation des
personnes visées dernier blocage et non
des moindres pour que les occultés la
France doit compter sur la collaboration
des pays des ressortissants étrangers
quand un individu n'a pas de papier
d'identité son pays d'origine doit
délivrer un laissez-passer consulaire
certains le font au compte-goutte un des
moyens de pression du gouvernement
français et de menacer de réduire le
nombre de visa accordé au pays comment
accorder des centaines de milliers de
vis apparents à des pays qui vous
refusent de reprendre deux personnes qui
trouvent leur de public et qui n'ont pas
leur titre territoire c'est impossible
une menace mise à exécution contre les
pays du Maghreb à l'automne 2021
bonsoir Julia Pasco allez merci d'avoir
patienté je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste au Monde que vous suivez les
questions migratoires pour ce grand
quotidien la France on voit on va le
voir notamment par rapport à l'Allemagne
il y a du mal à exécuter ces fameuses au
qtf le principal problème vous diriez
pour l'expliquer c'est ces fameux
laisser passer consulaires que les
consuls ont du mal à délivrer lorsque la
personne en question n'a pas de
passeport par exemple c'est un blocage
en effet mais il arrive déjà au bout de
la chaîne de l'éloignement en réalité
c'est pas le principal obstacle à
l'exécution des auqtf la France en
exécute moins en pourcentage que
l'Allemagne mais pour une raison assez
simple c'est qu'elle en délivre beaucoup
plus en réalité les préfectures des
livres des obligations de quitter le
territoire dans trois situations
principales
en cas de refus de titres de séjour en
cas de rejet d'une demande d'asile ou
cas plus minoritaire lors d'un contrôle
on va dire sur la voie publique par
exemple où on se rend compte que
l'étranger est sans titre on était libre
alors une qtf mais en réalité considérer
que la France n'est pas comment dire
mauvaise élève en la matière en fait ça
dépend comment on regarde les choses
aujourd'hui le taux d'exécution des
chiffres alors pour le premier semestre
5,6% mais il y a le contexte sanitaire
on va le mettre à part mais si on
remonte à 2019 12 % seulement
d'exécution c'est peu en réalité oui
bien sûr ici on regarde sur la dernière
décennie on arrive on atteint rarement
les 20% d'exécution mais parce qu'en
fait on délivre beaucoup d'obligations
de quitter le territoire français et et
on regarde les chiffres au global on a
comparé France-Allemagne certes en
Allemagne il y a moins de de délivrantes
de doc donc il y a plus d'exécution en
ratio mais la France est quand même en
retard par rapport à l'Allemagne si on
compare juste les masses en chiffres en
fait vous avez un taux d'exécution qui
est supérieur en Allemagne parce qu'il
cible leurs aucutés F parce que quand
ils prennent une occupé ils savent
qu'ils ont plus de chances de l'exécuter
en réalité en France on prend une auqtf
alors qu'on sait pertinemment enfin
l'administration c'est pertinemment
qu'elle n'a pas la personne entre la
main qu'elle peut pas prendre de mesures
coercitives à son rencontre et donc elle
elle a beaucoup de chance de ne pas
pouvoir exécuter cette éloignement et un
des principales obstacles alors on peut
dire c'est parce que l'étranger n'est
pas à la main de l'administration des
pouvoirs publics mais aussi parce que la
personne peut faire effectivement un
recours et peut-être à droit de se
maintenir sur le territoire on se rend
compte qu'il y a beaucoup alors
justement les rencontres juridictions
peut-être que voilà mettre
on dit beaucoup que les recours
contribuent à retarder justement la mise
en exécution de ses auditefs quand ils
ne sont pas forcément toujours jugés
recevable alors vous vous êtes
évidemment à vos cas des droits en droit
des étrangers évidemment ces personnes
ont des droits et il faut les faire
respecter c'est pour ça que les avocats
sont là pour le faire est-ce qu'il y a
des
les abus en matière de recours ou pas
alors d'abord il y a plusieurs types de
recours parce qu'il y a plusieurs délais
de recours certaines occultés F font
démarrer un recours très rapide de un
recours très rapide de 48 heures
d'autres de 15 jours d'autres de 30
jours donc déjà c'est vrai que quand on
a 48 heures pour contacter un avocat
c'est extrêmement court
ensuite c'est les
OCC en fait elles ont été introduites
par la loi du 24 juillet 2006 et au
départ le législateur avait imposé aux
juridictions administratives au tribunal
administratif de juger quand il y avait
un départ obligé dans un délai de trois
mois mais ils sont totalement débordés
les tribunaux parce qu'il y a eu
tellement de qtf et tellement de recours
qu'il n'arrive absolument pas à tenir ce
délai de trois mois on est plutôt en
région parisienne à six mois à 7 mois
avant d'avoir un jugement il est vrai
que quand on a fait un recours
d'ailleurs que le citoyen lui-même peut
faire pas seulement un avocat
c'est suspensif on ne peut pas
réellement procéder à l'exécution de
l'occupée
les recours pour toucher la du
juridictionnelle la fin les dossiers
sont liés je me fais l'avocat je pense
pas qu'on puisse faire se reproche au
magistrat administratif et il y a quand
même beaucoup d'eau qtf qu'on peut
annuler pour des raisons extrêmement
valables notamment d'inexacte après la
situation du requin je pense que c'est
important il y a un rapport sénatorial
qui donne un chiffre intéressant il y a
12% des éloignements qui sont empêchés
du fait de décision juridique et il faut
savoir que il y a des personnes enfin
les préfectures étudient les demandes de
titres de séjour des étrangers et
parfois enfin on le sait les préfectures
ont des moyens limités parfois examinent
mal les demandes de titres et parfois
font des erreurs d'appréciation et c'est
ça que le juge vient sanctionner
Benjamin Haddad là on est évidemment
face à des situations où il y a des
recours où la personne ne veut pas
évidemment être conduite à la frontière
rentrée dans son dans son pays d'origine
est-ce qu'au fond les retours
volontaires incités au retour volontaire
y compris financièrement la meilleure
solution si ça fait partie des options
qu'il faudra étudier nous dans nos
priorités on veut augmenter déjà
l'exécution de ces au qtf on a un
certain nombre de leviers on voit en
France alors par exemple en France vous
avez beaucoup de recours possibles vous
avez des temps de recours vous avez fait
que locuteur peut être suspendu au
moment de l'examen de certains recours
donc on veut pouvoir réduire les délais
réduire réduire les délais réduire
peut-être le nombre de recours ça c'est
en amont en aval on en a parlé tout à
l'heure il y a effectivement la question
les laisser passer des pays de retour ou
là on a déjà vu une augmentation assez
nette sur les pays d'Afrique du Nord par
exemple cette année depuis la politique
de restriction de visa qui a été menée
par le président de la l'exécution on le
voit dans les chiffres on le voit il y a
eu l'effet covid à la reprise et puis il
y a eu l'exécution par exemple sur les
pays comme la Tunisie ou même l'Algérie
et puis après je crois qu'il faut aussi
développer une doctrine c'est à dire que
l'objectif c'est pas juste de faire du
chiffre pour faire du chiffre la
question c'est de développer une
immigration de responsabilité de droit
et de devoirs c'est à dire que si vous
venez
en France pour travailler que vous
respectez les règles de la République
que vous voulez vous intégrer là je
dirais que c'est à la fois notre
tradition républicaine et notre intérêt
économique de même vous faciliter les
démarches qui sont parfois non mais bien
sûr que non mais même on veut faciliter
les démarches pour ceux qui veulent
venir travailler mais à l'inverse si
vous ne respectez pas les règles si vous
êtes délinquants par exemple comme l'a
dit le miso intérieur et bien là on va
renforcer les expulsions c'est cette
logique d'équilibre logique de droit et
de devoirs l'extrême droite depuis des
décennies nous parlent d'immigration
zéro mais tous les étrangers dans le
même sac nous une logique ou on veut
faciliter l'intégration de ceux qui
veulent venir respecter les règles de la
République et après les les faire
respecter si vous avez des cas de
délinquance pendant la campagne a eu ce
débat sur la question de l'État de droit
adapté ou pas notamment sur cette
politique de mise en oeuvre de ces de
ces obligations à quitter le territoire
le rassemblement national en est où sur
cette question mon faux suspendre des
tas de droit notamment Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme ou pas
non non pas du tout le rassemblement
national est un parti républicain donc
très respectueux de l'État de droit à
nos accords on reste dans on fait on
peut en renégocier certains toutefois il
faut avoir la lucidité pour voir et pour
dire que si aujourd'hui on a seulement 5
% des occultés qui sont appliquées c'est
qu'il y a un problème et donc il y a un
problème à plusieurs niveaux il y a un
certain nombre de blocages
administratifs c'est pour ça que nous
ferons des propositions de loi et
notamment nous apporterons nous
enrichirons le texte
vous écoute donc par exemple on peut
revoir le CZ voilà alors ça c'est quoi
c'est le c'est le code d'entrée du
séjour des étrangers et du droit d'asile
voilà donc on peut revoir le ceséda il
faut aussi travailler en amont parce que
aujourd'hui on se dit oui on n'arrive
pas à faire à piquer les auqtf bon
d'accord mais il y a quand même 600 000
clandestins environ qui sont sur notre
territoire donc on peut déjà commencer à
travailler à lutter contre
mais concrètement comment vous en donnez
dans le cadre de l'État de droit par
exemple on peut arrêter de subventionner
les associations immigrationnistes voilà
les associations qui font venir des
personnes qui ont destinant sur le
territoire ensuite on peut renforcer les
moyens des centres de rétention réfugiés
est-ce que ça vous revenez nous on fait
bien la distinction entre les vrais
réfugiés les vrais demandeurs d'asile et
ceux qui utilisent ces filières pour se
rendre clandestinement sur le territoire
national et donc je parlais des centres
de rétention administratif aujourd'hui
il y en a même pas 1900 en France voilà
il y a même pas 1900 places en France
avec 600 000 clandestins
il faut expliquer aux gens ce sont ces
espaces ce ne sont pas des prisons
peut-être Julia Pasqua vous pouvez nous
expliquer
ça donc dire que en plus de créer de
nouvelles places en centre de rétention
administrative il faut réarmer
moralement les policiers moi je connais
un certain nombre de policiers qui
travaillent dans ces centres de
rétention AD narrative ils sont
totalement démunis face à l'ampleur des
possibilités qui sont offertes aux
clandestins pour le coup et du coup la
parole des polices n'est des policiers
n'est pas du tout entendu et enfin il y
a un autre arme qui s'appelle la
diplomatie et quand on fait de la
diplomatie et bien on peut reconnaître
que Gérald Darmanin
avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'échecs moi ce que je vois c'est que
sur les laisser passer consulaires on
peut négocier en mettant en balance
l'aide au développement pourquoi on
continuerait de donner des milliards
d'euros à des pays qui en contrepartie
non seulement ne continue de délivrer
des visas à leur ressortissants et en
plus ne reprennent pas les
ressortissants qui causent le trouble
dans notre pays alors Julia Pasqual vous
qui êtes reporters sur le terrain si
j'ose dire est-ce que s'il y avait plus
de place dans les craws donc les centres
de rétention administrative les choses
pourraient ce qu'on peut dire sur le
terrain ce qu'on peut dire sur le temps
long enfin je sais que les du
gouvernement c'est de créer des places
supplémentaires ça a déjà été le cas
dans le précédent quinquennat il y a
actuellement en moyenne une loi
immigration tous les deux ans et on peut
regarder sur le temps long on a des des
volumes d'expulsion de de renvoi forcé
et d'étrangers qui sont peu ou Prous sur
des volumes stables on est autour de 10
20 000 retours forcés donc les réformes
législatives jusqu'à présent font pas de
miracle non plus et je pense qu'il faut
éviter les promesses les promesses
difficiles à ou impossible à tenir comme
quand le président de la République
parle de 100% d'exécution des eaux UTF
c'est tout simplement impossible vous
voulez faites ces promotions sont pas
tenables non mais le plus important je
crois que c'est d'être dans la maîtrise
c'est des de savoir en fait quel type de
personnalité on a envie d'expulser si
par exemple on a des cas de délinquance
là effectivement mettre les moyens sur
la réforme des recours sur les centres
de rétention sur la pression sur les
pays d'accueil pour pouvoir les expulser
et après faire venir ce dont notre pays
a besoin par exemple pour le travail ou
évidemment le droit d'asile finalement
ce que vous décriviez pas pas sur les
associations le tri entre les
associations
philosophique entre d'un côté un parti
qui pendant des décennies c'est toujours
fait le chantre de la fermeture absolue
et qui mélange toute forme d'immigration
tout les étrangers et nous on veut une
immigration responsable avec des droits
des voies choisis moi j'ai vécu à
l'étranger longtemps j'ai vécu aux
États-Unis là vous devez prouver que
vous avez un certain nombre de
compétences vous avez des entreprises
qui vont vous sponsoriser pour des visas
et pourtant c'est un pays ouvert comme
le nôtre à vocation à l'être maître
Corinne judiciaire les pistes de
solution du terrain de l'avocat dans le
droit des étrangers que vous êtes alors
vu de quel côté pour l'expulsion pour
retarder l'expulsion bon d'après ce que
j'entends ici le gros problème pour les
expulsions c'est qu'il y a personne qui
vient rechercher c'est ça le problème le
plus gros problème c'est à dire vous
avez une eau qtf mais il n'y a pas la
police qui vient taper à votre porte
pour vous pour vous mettre dehors donc
il y a manifestement un manque de moyens
n'est pas un délit dans notre pays on
peut pas vous poursuivre vous avez vous
avez en moyenne 520 000 au qtf par an
qui sont prises enfin vous imaginez les
moyens de policier ou de gendarmerie
qu'il faudrait mobiliser pour aller
chercher des gens chez eux enfin c'est
assez insensé en réalité les seuls
expulsions complaires en général c'est
les personnes qui sont dans l'écran ce
que vous avez indiqué donc les centres
de rétention administrative cela on peut
les expulser dans la mesure où on trouve
un passeport ou un laissez-passer
consulat et on ne peut pas les garder
dans ces centres là parce qu'il y a un
problème quand même de 90 dollars 90
jours avec deux que vous touchez pas si
vous étiez aux affaires
si on peut toucher au délai pour
raccourcir ses délais pour que ces
personnes soient renvoyées plus
rapidement on peut aussi faire en sorte
que le fait de se rentrer et de se
maintenir sur le territoire français
redevienne un acte répréhensible et
après tout ça c'est une question de
décision politique de choix politiques
oui au rassemblement national on
souhaite augmenter les moyens des forces
de l'ordre pour qu'elle puisse faire
appliquer la loi en France le
rendez-vous des solutions si j'ose dire
c'est la loi locmin la loi sur
l'immigration qui est d'abord au Sénat
puis à l'Assemblée c'est ça le
calendrier
va nous permettre d'augmenter de façon
considérable les budgets de la police
avec comme objectif de doubler la
présence de la police sur le terrain à
la fin du quinquennat c'est la
trajectoire d'augmentation on a mis fin
à une décennie de baisse de moyens et
après la loizill l'immigration qui est
effectivement renforcera les moyens au
début de l'année 2023
bon bah écoutez on verra ce qu'il y a
dans ce texte merci beaucoup merci
d'être venu sur le plateau LCP pour pour
ce débat écourté par un deuxième 49.3 on
va accueillir à présent notre grand
témoin il est économiste il est de
gauche et son Traité d'économie
hérétique fut un succès il revient avec
un dictionnaire mon dictionnaire
d'économie chez fayards un guide de
vulgarisation des principaux concepts
économiques pour nous aider à comprendre
pour aider aussi le lecteur à se
positionner et à débattre Thomas Porchet
nous rejoint juste après l'invitation
signé ce soir Marco pommier moi je
constate que la majorité des Français
trouve que l'économie ne fonctionne pas
bien et donc moi je voulais offrir en
fait un manuel d'autodéfense contre la
pensée dominante ce soir ce n'est pas le
champion de karaté que nous recevons
mais le docteur en économie très présent
dans les médias vous êtes aussi
professeur à la Paris School of Business
et membre du collectif les économistes
atterrées auteur d'une vingtaine
d'ouvrages vous êtes contre la doxane et
au libérale pour vous l'économie n'est
pas une science exacte il n'y a pas de
vérité en sciences dynamique et ça fait
quand même une trentaine d'années que
une certaine partie de la science
économique les économistes plutôt les
libéraux nous disent qu'il n'y a qu'une
seule voie Margaret Thatcher
Emmanuel Macron a dit l'autre politique
et amiral pas de vérité en économie
alors thomas Porcher ouvrons votre
dictionnaire à la lettre R pour retraite
pas question de réforme dites-vous avec
un taux de pauvreté chez les retraités
français parmi les plus faibles du monde
quant au choc démographique pour vous
c'est une chimère au mot carburant
thermomètre de la grogne sociale Vous
dénoncez une fiscalité injuste avec des
taxes sur l'essence qui représentent 50
à 60% du prix
l'État se prend 80 centimes minimum
dessus donc ça serait bien qui diminue
un petit peu les taxes sont un peu trop
élevées ce serait bien l'augmentation de
connaissance tout le monde baissé même
l'inflation à son mot dans votre
dictionnaire c'est plus que d'actualité
pour vous le danger ce sont les prix
supérieurs au salaire alors thomas
Porcher face à l'inflation face aux
salaires qui stagne et face à la crise
de l'énergie cette question comment nos
politiques peuvent reprendre la main sur
l'économie à vous la parole
[Musique]
et bonsoir thomas Porcher bonsoir
bienvenue sur ce plateau c'est donc un
livre engagé on l'a bien compris il est
aussi enlever souvent drôle il faut
dédramatiser l'économie qui intimide
dites-vous on en a si peur qu'il fallait
un dictionnaire de combat c'est ça
l'idée c'est exactement ça en fait
l'économie c'est abstrait pour un
certain nombre de gens en France et donc
soit ils veulent pas se positionner soit
ils répètent des idées qui sont devenus
maintenant un peu même presque je dirais
des urbanes légendes par exemple alors
attention il faut baisser la dépense
publique mais il y a quoi dans la
dépense publique on ne sait pas il faut
réduire la dette sinon on va être on va
être mangé par le grand méchant loup
mais là on a vu que la dette a augmenté
finalement n'a pas été mangé par le
grand méchant loup donc il y a tout un
tas de choses comme ça qu'il faut
décanter pour que les gens puissent
avoir une position ferme et puis qui
bouscule un petit peu les politiques
il faut pas travailler moins enfin
travailler plus pardonnez-moi manuel
d'autodéfense contre la pensée dominante
si dominante que ça vraiment est-ce
qu'on peut dire qu'on est toujours dans
la doxa néolibéral que vous dénoncez
quand on voit que le mot protectionnisme
je n'ai plus un gros mot dans la bouche
de Bruno Le Maire quand on voit le
bouclier tarifaire qui va être reconduit
même s'il est un peu baissé sont des
milliards pour protéger les Français
après le quoi qu'il en coûte de la crise
sanitaire est-ce que c'est pas
caricatural par rapport au fond à un
tournant dans lequel même la pensée
libérale est passée quoi il y a une
parenthèse pendant le covid et qui a
fait qu'un certain nombre de mots de
vocabulaire sont revenus et je le dis
par exemple pour plan de relance ou état
stratège et dit voilà c'est des mots
donc on entend beaucoup parler
maintenant y compris dans la dans la
bouche de de des gens du gouvernement
des politiques pas tant que ça parce que
vous regardez par exemple là sur sur le
budget là qui fait l'objet justement
d'un 49-3 vous regardez la fiche qui a
été rendue à la commission par le
gouvernement c'est une augmentation des
dépenses publiques de 0,6%, c'est hors
inflation donc c'est moins que
l'inflation donc on va faire des
économies sur la dépense publique parce
qu'on veut réduire très rapidement et
déficits c'est exactement ce qu'on a
fait en 2011 qui qui a fait qu'on a eu
cette crise de la zone euro et donc il y
a Bruno Le Maire qui dit tout le temps
on refera pas comme en 2011 on refera
pas comme en 2011 très bien alors
pourquoi il fait comme en 2011 c'est ça
la question moi que je lui pose donc
c'est l'austérité il y a eu une
parenthèse bien sûr que là il y a bah là
il y a de l'austérité qui va avoir lieu
là c'est clair
les dettes des états ou avec un risque
de quoi alors vous savez la dette a
augmenté partout très fortement moi je
me souviens juste avant le covid une
semaine avant qu'on soit tous confiné
j'étais ici pour un autre livre et
j'avais dit devant Olivier Faure vous
savez moi les déficits je m'en soucie
pas trop l'important c'est de l'argent
qui a à l'hôpital et au service public
et puis une semaine après on a eu le
covid on s'est rendu compte que
l'hôpital avait besoin d'argent et les
gens ont dit on être inventé mais
Manuela conduit je vais me réinventer de
la puissance du pays les déficits quand
on est les États-Unis qu'on a une une
monnaie très forte refuge une économie
d'avenir
la France peut se permettre l'Europe
pour espérer mettre ça déjà parce que
l'euro est une monnaie importante aussi
et quand vous voyez que le plan de
relance américaine est beaucoup plus
fort que le plan de relance européen que
les déficits sont beaucoup plus creusés
aux États-Unis qu'en Europe moi je me
dis qu'on pourrait faire la même chose
en Europe mais pour faire ça il faut
qu'il y ait des gens qui défendent ça et
aujourd'hui il y a personne qui défend
ça en Europe tout le monde défend la
réduction rapide des déficits comme en
2011 c'est ça que je dis en fait dans
mon livre c'est que si on veut un moment
qui a une nouvelle Europe bah il faut un
peu bousculer les institutions
européennes
quoi qu'il en coûte c'était c'était une
très bonne chose je veux dire mais le
plan de relance on nous a dit que
c'était un plan de relance mais moi j'ai
cité Agnès Benassi kere qui est quand
même une économiste avec qui j'ai
beaucoup de désaccords et qui au trésor
aujourd'hui et qui a dit elle-même que
c'était pas un plan de relance keynésien
en réalité c'était plutôt un plan de
compétitivité de transformation de
l'économie à la dit parce que là-dedans
il y a des baisses d'impôts encore pour
les entreprises et qu'est-ce qui se
passe en fait cette parenthèse qu'on a
eu pendant le covid en fait c'est une
parenthèse où ça a contredit toutes les
réformes qu'avaient fait avant Emmanuel
Macron les économie s'est dit c'est pour
ça qu'il a dit qu'il allait se
réinventer ça la contredire et puis là
on repart sur la même chose et moi je
pensais que c'est justement que le covid
allait être un changement beaucoup plus
radical et qu'on repart sur la même
chose c'est un vrai problème alors la
priorité des priorités pour les Français
c'est l'inflation vous dites à
l'occurrence inflation que le problème
c'était pas l'augmentation des prix
c'est la vitesse avec laquelle il
progresse en comparaison des revenus
est-ce que vous êtes favorable au retour
de l'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation et moi je pense que on
devrait au moins poser mais au moins
discuter d'une indexation des salaires
en dessous d'un certain revenu d'un
certain salaire je veux dire en dessous
de 3000 euros par unité de consommation
vous voyez bah là on peut se dire
peut-être que là on indique cela et
parce que en haut vous ressentez moins
l'inflation quand vous êtes dans les
dans les dans les trois premiers des
cils vous ressentez moins l'inflation
que quand vous êtes dans les dans les
autres des sites et que vous vivez en
plus en dehors de Paris où vous utilisez
plus votre voiture il faut poser ce
débat mais pourquoi pour le poser parce
que vos confrères
beaucoup d'économies pas tous c'est vrai
il y a quand même une sorte de consensus
là-dessus c'est la spirale
inflationniste la boucle le prix salaire
si vous réindexer voilà ça va s'emballer
et surtout avec une croissance faible on
a connu ça pendant le choc pétrolier
pourquoi il ne faut pas craindre ce
scénario là on explique-nous bien sûr il
faut regarder mais là ce qui nous disent
les économistes les autres ils mettent
ils assistent le chiffon de
l'hyperinflation alors on a 6 %
d'inflation on irait à l'hyperinflation
de l'Argentine avec 20000% enfin on en
est loin on en est loin il y a des
économistes beaucoup d'économistes
Monsieur Robert Barraud professeur
Harvard d'autres du FMI que j'ai cité et
d'autres de Cambridge comme as-tu une
chambre qui disent que en fait en
dessous de 10% d'inflation il y a pas
d'impact sur la croissance en dessous de
20% d'inflation il y a un impact très
négligeable sur la croissance c'est ce
que disent aussi un certain nombre
d'économistes de grandes institutions de
Harvard et d'ailleurs donc moi je dis
indexon au moins c'est salaire entre
3000 euros par unité de consommation et
surveillons l'inflation si on passe à 7
8 9 % quel est l'impact rien du tout et
là il y a des gens qui vous disent ah
non non surtout faut pas toucher les
salaires parce que on va avoir 20000 %
d'inflation comme en Argentine enfin il
y a un certain nombre de facteurs qui
font que l'inflation se transforme en
hyper inflation c'est des facteurs qui
montrent qu'il y a une surchauffe de
l'économie ou parce que parfois vous
avez des politiques qui veulent
s'emparer de panier de l'économie on en
est pas là et on peut se permettre de
bien piloter en augmentant les salaires
exactement
quand l'économie de devient forcément
politique c'est que le mouvement social
sera là pour obliger les entreprises ils
parient sur le fait que les Français
sont suffisamment résignés pour ne pas
le faire donc il se contente de faire
des appels aux entreprises même parmi
les plus riches on avait que l'affaire
totale pour augmenter les salaires mais
elles ne veulent pas le faire si elles
ne veulent pas le faire il faut un
moment que ce soit l'économie qui pilote
le politique qui pilote ça mais il
refuse de le faire c'est un tabou alors
Bruno Le Maire a parlé c'est ma dernière
question aujourd'hui il est plutôt
optimiste lui voit l'inflation diminuée
et il parle d'un objectif pour 2024 d'un
retour à 3% d'inflation vous pouvez le
croire parce que d'autres
faire le FCE par exemple est sur un
pouvoir d'achat qui qui va cesser de
baisser nous verrons mais je sais pas
d'où ils tirent cette avec quoi
d'assurance d'être aussi optimiste y
compris sur la croissance une prévision
croissance bien plus optimiste peut-être
qu'il aura raison mais je sais pas d'où
il tire c'est cette optimiste nous
verrons mais en tous les cas quoi qu'il
en soit aujourd'hui nous avons une très
forte baisse du pouvoir d'achat pour les
salariés et qui est un véritable
problème on ne peut pas faire comme si
cette baisse de pouvoir d'achat
n'existait pas c'est à dire ce
dictionnaire c'est le vôtre mon
dictionnaire d'économie un manuel de
combat et pas seulement pour les gens de
gauche ça s'adresse à tous les lecteurs
vous êtes ouvert au débat thomas Porcher
c'est chez Fayard et puis il y a des
occurrences très rigolotes comme homme
déconstruit que vous assumez être ou
encore bobo vous restez avec moi thomas
Porcher il est temps à présent
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris ils sont deux ce soir le
regard de Richard Werly d'abord pour
commencer sur le naufrage de listrus
contrainte de démissionner aujourd'hui
après un passage éclair au thème Downing
Street et puis Vincent hugueux qui va
revenir sur le retour en France de 40
enfants de djihadistes et de 14 mères
autour de Syrie c'est un tournant dans
la doctrine française nos affranchis les
voici bonsoir messieurs ravis de vous
retrouver rien ne va plus à Londres
Richard vous allez nous expliquer ce qui
a pu se passer tous ces tous ces
déroulés dans la journée liste sa
révérence après 6 semaines seulement
passer au thème d'industrie et pour vous
tout ça c'est la cause du brexit et bien
oui Myriam le brexit c'est le coupable
parce que ce le divorce chaotique du
Royaume-Uni avec l'Union européenne qui
je le rappelle est survenu après un
référendum le 23 juin 2016 il explique
tout c'est à cause du brexit que Theresa
May vous souvenez on en avait beaucoup
parlé sur ce plateau et bien qui était
arrivé au pouvoir juste après elle avait
chuté puis elle avait été poussé vers la
sortie par Boris Johnson c'est aussi à
cause du brexit que Boggio a pris le
pouvoir lui en juillet 2019 et puis
ensuite il l'a perdu en raison des
soirées de son gouvernement le fameux
party guette en plein confinement et
c'est le brexit qui vient de tuer
listrus pour une raison simple elle
avait d'abord voté elle pour le maintien
de son pays dans l'Union européenne donc
il y a eu une volte-face et c'est
toujours compliqué à gérer en politique
et puis ensuite il y a eu ce programme
d'impôts massif et l'espérée que les
marchés financiers diraient tous youpi
c'est le compteur qui s'est passé parce
que le Royaume-Uni abo est une île il a
besoin de bonne relation économiques
avec l'Union européenne il a besoin
d'être arrivé au marché européen et sa
politique elle allait en contradiction
alors est-ce qu'elle a été tuée par le
brexit oui d'autant plus que la
coïncidence du jour est fatal au moment
même où elle était devant le 10 Downing
sweet pour annoncer sa démission et bien
les chefs d'État de gouvernement des 27
étaient à Bruxelles pour ouvrir le
sommet européen alors comment en sortir
est-ce que le fantôme du brexit va finir
par se dissiper au Royaume-Uni et ben
moi je pense que non parce que
l'histoire ça fait fondamentalement 2
erreurs la première erreur c'est qu'elle
a cru je le répète que les marchés
financiers sautent et de joie parce
qu'on annonce des baisses d'impôts sauf
que la guerre en Ukraine elle tétaniste
tout le monde et que les pays du Sud a
commencé par l'Inde l'ancienne
britannique et bien quand on va aller
voir et qu'on leur demande des accords
de libre-échange ils demandent qu'est-ce
que le Royaume-Uni a offrir or le
Royaume-Uni n'a pas grand chose à offrir
je rappelle aussi que c'est gisements de
pétrole et de gaz qui se situe en Écosse
sont quand même en très très net
diminution puis la deuxième erreur c'est
qu'elle a confondu opportunité et
popularité alors elle a su éliminer ses
rivaux dont l'ancien ministre des
Finances Richie Sénac mais elle n'a pas
de base au sein du parti elle en a
d'autant moins qu'il y en a un qui
rêvent toujours de revenir c'est Boris
Johnson donc le problème il est toujours
le même et un retour aux urnes pour
l'instant ne le réglera pas c'est qu'en
réalité ce dont tu as besoin le
Royaume-Uni c'est d'un accord de
partenariat avec l'Union européenne un
partenariat durable solide pour ça il
faut avoir du courage et en ce moment
même l'opposition travailiste n'a pas le
courage de le proposer merci en quelques
mots d'accord avec l'analyse de brexit a
tué l'histoire je pense pas que ce soit
ça je pense que le brexit c'est un vote
de gens qui se sont opposés à la
mondialisation et au libéralisme en
partie parce que
c'est ça et en fait les gens qui ont
pris le pouvoir après ils ont été encore
plus loin dans cette logique
une espèce d'impôt massive etc donc ils
ont perdu avec le brexit la City les
milieux financiers qui sont fâchés
contre eux et ils ont pas non plus
rassuré les classes populaires qui ont
voté pour le brexit donc ils ont tout
perdu
donc c'est comme la photo brexit Vincent
alors vous vouliez revenir aujourd'hui
sur une des informations importantes de
la journée la France a rapatrié 55
femmes et enfants qui avaient rallié
l'État islamique est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est dangereux de faire ça est-ce
que ça risque de raviver les polémiques
et puisque le cirque démago populiste ne
fait jamais relâche puisqu'il déploie
son chapiteau dès lors que les mots
djihadistes et rapatriement figurent
dans la même phrase bref rappelle
factuel d'abord donc l'année dernière 15
femmes 40 enfants détenus jusqu’alors
dans un camp du nord-est de la Syrie
sous contrôle des forces kurdes ont
atterri à Villacoublay les mineurs
seront confiés au service
de l'aide à l'enfance comme toujours
quant aux adultes elles ont été remises
les autorités judiciaire compétente
lesquelles agiront en fonction de la
nature de leur engagement au sein du
défunt Khalifa Irak au syrien de daesh
est-ce que c'est
un tour très en France alors disons que
ça confirme effectivement un changement
de posture l'infection de la doctrine en
la matière longtemps adossé à la logique
du cas par cas date de juillet dernier
pour preuve le retour dans l'Hexagone à
l'époque d'une cinquantaine de captifs
dont 35 gamins et ado il faut dire
qu'entre temps la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme a condamné la France
pour son peu d’empressement à traiter
les demandes de rapatriement ce qui bien
sûr ne suffit pas à solder un défi
colossal non bien sûr rien ne sert de se
planquer derrière le paravent de la
candeur et du déni le sort des égarés de
daesh astreint toutes démocratie à un
casse-tête logistique juridique humain
sécuritaire sur un pays le nôtre en
l'occurrence meurtri par diné façade
carnage terroriste que les faux
prophètes du diad Global ont orchestré
ou inspiré flottent toujours la
tentation de laisser leur disciple
étouffer l'été puis je les libère dans
des camps cloaques lointains après tout
le concept même de rapatriement prêt à
controverse que signifie revenir dans
une patrie que l'on ne juge pas sienne
et on a répudié les valeurs alors
justement que deviennent ces valeurs au
regard d'une telle épreuve au vent
mauvais de la vengeance mène tout droit
à une impasse l'État ne peut s'exonérer
de ses responsabilités si tant de jeunes
femmes françaises né en France on cédait
aux sirènes funeste de daesh c'est aussi
que les défaillances de notre logiciel
social système éducatif en tête les ont
rendu perméables à un tel poison et que
dire des enfants dont la plupart
d’ailleurs ont vu le jour en captivité
au nom de quoi devrait-il expier les
péchés de leurs parents je sais bien que
l'air du temps est plus propice au
simplisme qu'à la nuance mais je sais
surtout que le plus sûr moyen de combler
nos ennemis c'est de transiger avec les
principes de droit comme avec l'idéal
humaniste que nous prétendons défendre
et incarner merci beaucoup Vincent c'est
l'honneur de la de faire revenir ses
enfants de djihadiste avec leur mère
théoriquement je dirais que oui après je
suis pas suffisamment calé sur la
question pour avoir un avis tranché mais
vous êtes un citoyen engagé et vous
l'assumez merci beaucoup merci les
affranchis merci thomas Porcher mon
dictionnaire d'économie comprendre ce
positionner débattre c'est-à-dire chez
Fayard très belle soirée à vous elle
commence avec un documentaire soirée
orchestrée par Jean-Pierre Gratien comme
tous les soirs quant à moi je vous
retrouve demain même lui même heure
[Musique]